um
okay i think we have the wall uh live transmission
thing on um so it's my pleasure to introduce our
color cam speaker for today with karen adolf um
and she's gonna talk to us about her work in the
infant action lab which is the head of um and
that's very exciting work to me because there's
not many uh psychological works and especially
when it comes to development that are highly
ecological uh but i think that's what karen has
pioneered and does incredibly well so i hope you
will all enjoy it as much as i will and karen the
first is yours thank you let me share my screen
can you guys see my my slides yes yes perfect i
am very happy to be here i wish i was there there
and not just remote but i'm delighted to tell
you about the research that we're doing at nyu
and i wanted to start by showing you these
beautiful videos from a paper by hunting
colleagues showing beautifully calibrated and
beautifully executed behaviors by wild backyard
squirrels these wild squirrels are amazing
they can gauge their leaps they use amazing
parkour strategies bouncing off the back wall to
exploit features of the environment and they do it
all with acrobatic grace and agile landings and
in our perspectives on this research we argued
that learning to move in the real world is the
primary function of behavioral development but
hunt and colleague squirrels were all adults with
a lifetime of learning to leap around the backyard
studying behavior in adults can't tell us how it
develops how you get from this to this to this
my presentation is about behavioral
development in human infants so i
want to know how do you get from this on
day one of walking to this 100 days later
and these video snippets represent
the three major themes of my work
behavior development and the power of video
to capture behavior and its development why
focus on behavior because it's everything
we do it's why we have brains that's why
animals have brains and for animals like
squirrels and human infants it's the only
window that researchers have into perception
and cognition and other psychological processes
so i'm going to tell you some of the big
lessons that i've learned over the last 30
years what develops i think most important is that
behavior becomes more flexible more adaptive and
more functional we go from like bumbling toddlers
to the equivalent of hunts adult squirrels
here's an example this thing here is an adjustable
drop-off apparatus so it can have really small
drop-offs like a step that afford locomotion
a really large drop off like a cliff where
locomotion is impossible there's visual and haptic
information available to tell infants about the
relations between their body and the environment
and babies can get perceptual information from
looking and from touching experienced 12 month
old crawlers select their actions adaptively
so they'll easily crawl down drop-offs that are
within their ability but they will not attempt
to crawl down drop-offs that are beyond their
ability but look what happens in the same age of
infants who are new walkers novice walkers will
repeatedly attempt to walk down drop-offs that
are beyond their ability they seriously do even
on a 90 centimeter drop-off new walkers will go
straight over the edge they behave as if they have
no clue about the limits of their own abilities
but six months later after infants have
several months of walking experience
again they select their actions adaptively
and they can perceive precisely within one
centimeter of accuracy whether a drop-off is
safe for walking experienced 18 month old walkers
look like experienced 12 month old crawlers
they know precisely if the drop off is too
high for walking and if it's too high for
walking they'll find an alternative strategy
and you know these aren't parkour strategies like
adult squirrels but experienced walkers are not
learning fixed associations or static solutions
they're searching for and discovering multiple
solutions so you know if it's within their
ability like this 13 centimeter drop off
then walkers will walk over it but if it's
beyond their ability even slightly beyond
like this 15 centimeter drop off then infants
find alternative solutions like crawling
or um if it's um too high for crawling they might
scoot down like on the 19 centimeter drop off
or back down um and here's the thing learning
fixed solutions that would be stupid in a variable
world that needs new solutions for new tasks
here's data so zero here represents the largest
drop-off that each infant could navigate so the
data are normalized to each infant's abilities
the negative numbers are drop-offs that are
smaller than the threshold so these are safe
the positive numbers are drop-offs that are
larger than the threshold so these are risky
and there's a really easy one centimeter drop
off and a really huge cliff sized 90 centimeter
drop off this red curve here this is experienced
12 month old crawlers these babies are perfect
they're probability matching they're matching
the probability of attempting to crawl to the
conditional probability of success but here i've
added in blue the novice walkers they're vastly
overestimating their ability to walk they'll
attempt to walk over a drop off that's nine
centimeters too large on 75 percent of trials
they'll attempt that 90 centimeter drop off on 50
of trials this group is the same age as the
experienced crawlers the difference is that they
had not learned to perceive the relation between
the draw puff and their new locomotor posture
now i've added the 18 month old experience
walkers in green and they perceive
equally well as experienced crawlers so babies
are coordinating perception and action through
experience with that perception action system
crawling experience teaches infants to perceive
possibilities for curling walking experience
teaches infants to perceive possibilities for
walking and there's no evidence of transfer
from earlier to later developing skills
longitudinal data show really dramatically
that there's no transfer from earlier to
later developing perception action systems
so this is a typical infant in the first
week of crawling and they have no idea if they
can crawl down a slope they'll try them and fall
um but 10 weeks later their errors have dropped
to 50 so half the time they'll correctly reject
the slope but it's too steep for crawling and
avoid going or back down like this baby did and
then by 20 weeks of crawling experience they have
really fast really efficient exploratory movements
and they can perceive precisely within two degrees
of slant whether a slope is safe for crawling but
then when the same babies stand up the next week
as new walkers facing the same slopes all over
again they have no clue about the limits of their
abilities and they made just as many errors as
they had done in the first week of of crawling 10
weeks later again their errors have dropped to 50
they're not even faster the second time
around learning just starts all over again
so flexible adaptive behavior develops what do
infants learn they're learning to perceive and
to exploit new possibilities for action part
of the learning includes discovering and honing
the right exploratory actions learning from an
earlier developing skill doesn't transfer to a
later developing skill why not because new skills
create new body environment relations and new
skills meaning there's new information gathering
systems the possibilities for crawling and walking
for example they're different because there's
different relations between the body and the
environment there's also different vantage points
relative to the ground there's different visual
and haptic and proprioceptive information there's
different forces acting on different body parts
this research with babies on
drop-offs and slopes and whatnot
it highlights a critical aspect
of behavioral development
behavior develops in a changing body
with changing skills in a changing world
infants growth is dramatic and
it's episodic babies can grow nearly two
centimeters in height in a single day
and their bodies change from moment to moment
depending on the clothes that they wear and
whatever the shoes on their feet and
the objects that they're carrying
and infants motor skills change dramatically
especially for posture and for locomotion
how children can move affects their potential
access to the environment what they see what
they touch where they go their visual manual
and whole body access to the environment we find
that the environment essentially
develops and behavior develops in tandem
here's a nice example it's
the developmental transition
from crawling to walking walking literally
brings more of the world into view
here's a crawling infant's view of the world when
babies are crawling their visual access is limited
to the floor right in front of their hands
all they can see is the floor right in front
of their hands but this is what walkers see when
babies are upright the whole room swoops into view
these schematics show the average field of view
for crawling compared to walking while they're
crawling infants see mostly the floor while
they're walking they can see the whole room why
because in a curling position the
head necessarily points down posture
constrains visual access because of how the
head and neck are positioned on the human torso
on the top here you're seeing a third person
camera view and on the bottom you're seeing
what that person is seeing through a head mounted
eye tracker this is kind of a proof of concept
you'll see in a minute look in a supine posture
when you're lying on your back the position where
young babies spend a lot of their day visual
access is severely limited so of course they can
look up at the ceiling that's what you're seeing
right there but turning the head it like it rolls
the environment from the ceiling to the floor
rather than rotating it and turning the head the
other way rolls the room from the floor to the
ceiling and back to the floor on the other side
we use head mounted eye tracking we did that
with adults for ground truth it's a kind of
sanity check but this visualization that i'm
going to show you is what a person sees based
on the magic of computer vision using only third
person camera views we don't have to put anything
on the baby in a supine posture head position is
limited largely to rolling around the body access
and because pitch capabilities that means like
being able to lift your head up or chin up or
chin down is limited when you're lying on your
back visual access is like a two-dimensional fan
with the base at the head and then the vectors
projecting toward the walls and the ceiling
in a crawling posture which is how most babies
learn to move lifting their chin up only brings
part of the front wall into view and with
their head pointing down or in the natural
straight ahead position their field of view
is filled with the floor rotating the head
rolls the environment up to a wall and then if you
turn your head back rolls down to the
floor and then back up to the other wall
as a consequence turning the head in a crawling
posture results in a downward fan along the floor
and the ability to slightly lift and lower
your chin while you're curling creates a cross
that goes from the bottom of the front wall down
to the floor maybe the knees so visual access
and crawling is really limited very low to the
ground zone of visual access but in an upright
posture like sitting and standing visual access
is great because you can lift your head to look at
the ceiling you can lower your chin and look down
at the floor and you can rotate your head to view
the room on one side and um and then rotate
your head to view the room on the other side
the volume of visual access in a sitting or
a standing posture when you're upright so
your head is perched you know in this position
on your torso it's like there's a hemisphere
of possible places to look and it
goes all the way from the ceiling
down to the floor and it includes
more than 180 degrees of room rotation
we're currently testing how babies developing
motor skills affect their visual manual and whole
body access to the environment and we can actually
quantify access with pixel level precision
we're testing infants from 1 to 18 months so
essentially when they can just lie on their
back to when babies can run and climb and
jump and we're recording them in a complex
toy field playroom so they're free to do
whatever they want to do this playroom is
filled with visual barriers but also really
cool interesting stuff to see and to do
we've just started in-person data collection again
um but at every age babies start out lying supine
on a mat um in the same location and then using
only computer vision we capture what the
babies see what they touch and where they go
behavior develops in a changing body
with changing skills in a changing world
bodies and skills constrain interactions
with the environment and actually filter
the information from the environment because
bodies and skills develop the environment
also develops as gomes marin and gunzafar
put it in their beautiful paper which they
titled the life of behavior which is
such a good title excellent wonderful
title they said all animals share a common
world but not all animals have a world in common
what drives improvements in behavior
practice and what kinds of practice
immense amounts of time distributed
variable practice this graph
shows the accumulated number of steps per hour
plotted against days of walking each symbol is
one infant's spontaneous walking in a lab
playroom that's set up with toys and elevations
babies walk a lot average 2 400 steps per hour
that's like 14 000 steps in a waking day we see
the same thing in new samples of infants tested
in a lab playroom set up with different toys and
different elevations in different configurations
we see the same thing when we record walking
and infants homes we see the same thing in
new studies of natural activity in the home
practice is time distributed
it's not like a death march
this figure shows timelines of walking bouts for
60 babies over 30 minutes of spontaneous walking
each row is one baby the little births of black
are the time when infants are walking so their
walking is happening in little bursts of activity
that are separated by longer periods of rest
practice is a lot about starting and stopping not
continually going so watch this baby's right foot
so she's stationary and then that's the
whole walking ball just that one little step
short belts are common across development
more than 30 of all bouts have only one or
two or three steps of course babies can take
longer bouts and they often do but a lot of
the time it's only one or two or three steps
practice is variable relatively few walking paths
are straight only 25 percent are straight paths
instead walking inputs walk along
variable curvy windy paths 75 are curved
and there's curved paths across development
curved paths and brand new walkers curved
paths and experienced walkers
this is just how babies walk
there's they take steps in every direction so
step direction is variable most of their belts
contain steps that are not forward their steps are
omnidirectional they're forward and backward and
sideways i'm going to play it again at half speed
so you can see what i mean this baby takes one
two sideways steps then one two three forward
steps and then one two three backwards steps
less than 20 of belts have only forward
steps most of the bouts have a mixture
like you saw of forward and not forward
steps and 25 have no forward steps at all
as true cross development that means taking steps
in every direction is not a characteristic of poor
walking skill babies do it and
their first week of walking
and they're doing it nine months
later this is just how they walk
practice is not perfect behavior is fallible
infants walking is filled with errors
babies fall all the time they follow their
plane they trip over their own feet they fall
when they try to sit down they fall and they
try to stand up babies fall all the time
they fall a lot so infants average 39 falls for
every hour that they're in motion they follow a
lot but they don't care and their parents don't
care infants everyday falls are so trivial that
babies rarely fuss and their caregivers rarely
show concern 91 of falls that's this big green
bar they're uneventful and they largely go un
unmarked by babies or caregivers and infants are
back at play right away even after a big fall
this baby is back at play within three seconds
on average infants recover from their faults
within two seconds and babies don't decrease
their walking or shy away from the objects or the
places in the room that are associated with their
falls this baby fell 15 times with this stroller
but the false didn't discourage her from walking
with the stroller across babies they walk just
as much before fall as they do after a fall
one factor that mitigates the impact
of falling is the size and shape and
composition of infants bodies babies
are short and they're low to the ground
and they're padded with baby
fat and they move slowly
the potential energy generated by an infant fall
is 18 times less than if infants were
adult-sized and walked at adult speeds
another reason why falling is so trivial
is that infants display reactive behaviors
that mitigate the impact forces so
here's a baby she trips and falls
there's the trip and then she took a reactive
step and a second reactive step and bent her knees
during landing and braced herself
on nearby furniture and arrested
the fall with outstretched hands and it all
happens in a quick flash of 680 milliseconds
the natural input for learning is truly
immense immense amounts of time distributed
variable practice during everyday activity
practice is imperfect babies are fallible but
that's okay because errors are generally trivial
and they don't dissuade infants from
practicing until the point of mastery
what motivates infants to get all that
practice you know why do babies move
well one common sense hypothesis is that
infants are moving to get to the people
and places and things that they see well to
test whether where infants look influences
where they then go we fitted babies
with head mounted eye trackers
if infants really move to go to a destination
then they should look at something while
they're stationary and then go to it here's
what a destination directed belt looks like
that there's that baby the baby sees that little
ball on the green box and then walks to it
okay that's destination directed but it turns out
those kind of bouts are pretty rare it's like 18
of infants walking bouts it's also
possible that infants discover something
while they're traveling so and this kind
of about infants start looking at whatever
um you know so like she sees the saxophone
and keeps walking and spots something else now
it's the green alligator and that becomes the
destination but discovery belts are also rare
what's happening the rest of the time infants
start moving they're looking all over and
they start walking and they're still looking
everywhere and seeing lots of good stuff but
then they just stop walking in the middle
of the floor they're not going to anything
most of their bouts don't involve a destination
at all while they're stationary they're looking
at whatever then they start walking and they
just stop walking in the middle of the room
they're not going toward any recognizable
destination they're just moving to move
but if it were really true that objects are
not needed to instigate locomotion then infants
should move just as much in a completely
empty room as in a room filled with toys
so we tested infants playing in a room filled with
toys they were actually toys designed to encourage
locomotion and compared their locomotion to
infants in the same room with all the toys removed
we find that infants walk just as much in
an empty room as in a room filled with toys
they spend the same amount of time in motion
they take the same number of steps per hour
and they travel the same distance per hour and
in both conditions infants go to the same low
percentage of destinations only like 30 percent
counting any kind of destination in the toy room
infants mostly went to toys in the empty room
infants went you know went to their caregivers or
like the most interesting thing in that
room and they also went to features of
the room like the doorknob or the wall or
bits of little carpet fluff on the floor
what differs is that infants in the toy room
spend less time near their caregiver she's
no longer the most interesting thing in the
room and infants in the toy room explore more
of the playroom the difference is really clear
when you look at individual infants paths
these are paths from one infant in the toy
room one infant in the no toy room the black
dot is the caregiver she's just sitting on
a chair the whole time filling out forms
these two infants took a similar number of steps
but they covered very different amounts of area
infants in the toy room travel all over but
infants in the no toy room repeat their paths
here's all of infant's paths ordered
by the amount of area that they
covered infants in the toy field room
cover more area in the same amount of steps
movement achieves goals of course it does but
it's also its own reward at least for infants
babies learn to move in a physical environment
that's filled with stuff and sometimes they move
to goals but they also move spontaneously with
no goal in sight and no goal in mind all of that
movement leads to enhanced opportunities for
learning and for improvements in walking skill
we find that the variable
way that infants you know
run around promotes learning and
generalization and simulated robots
so how can you know how can you really know
whether all that you know self-generated crazy
walking is good for anything well to test whether
the whey infants walk is a good way to acquire
flexible and functional behavior we taught
simulated robots to walk using real infant
data this is a simulated robot from peter stone's
lab being trained to walk along different paths
and then the success of this training is evaluated
with robot soccer why soccer well because soccer
requires behavioral flexibility and adaptability
and creativity and function sucker it's kind of
like real life because it's unpredictable
there's novel stuff there's variable stuff
there's other dynamic active agents there's
goals and the other agents have goals
in tournament one we asked how training
robots on geometric paths would compare to
training robots on real baby paths now you
might think that training you know a robot
in a straight line is an unfair comparison
but straight path training was the most
typical way to train robots before peter stone
came along and walking in a straight line or on
a treadmill is actually the most popular type
of intervention for children with disabilities
the short answer is that babies win across
a thousand matches between each pair of
teams babies show the largest average goal
difference in tournament two we clustered 75
infant's paths into five groups based on
the variability of their walking in terms
of path shape whether they were both curved and
straight paths changes in direction path length
whether they were both long and short paths
the number and the number of starts and stops
and the purple team was the most variable on every
measure so within infants is more variety better
yes the purple team that trained on the
most varied infant walking pals outscored
all the other teams and won the most
games moreover the purple team's training
generalized better to untrained paths
these robots traveled faster and farther
on new paths together these data suggest that the
high variability that we observe in infant walking
constitutes a natural training measurement
that's beneficial for learning to move
and when we model different penalties for falling
with simulated robots just like with babies no
penalty at all leads to the greatest transfer
and flexibility why well skills that require vast
creativity and generativity and flexibility skills
like walking it's best if there's no penalty
for errors in early stages of learning so that
making mistakes doesn't stop infants from trying
and i want to end with a
pitch for open video sharing
that's where data brewery comes in data brewery is
a web-based library for research videos so that's
why we call it data breary because it's a library
for data it's a library for the secure ethical
open sharing of research videos the aim is to
make behavior accessible to researchers everywhere
video uniquely documents procedures and findings
you can see exactly what researchers did and
how the participants responded that will increase
research transparency and reproduce stability
video is uniquely suited for reuse so
you can ask questions that go beyond
the scope of the original study questions the
original researchers had never even imagined
by sharing and reusing videos we can capitalize on
each other's expertise and we can speed progress
data breathe preserves our history
it automatically transcodes videos
into preservable formats it will
organize and store videos indefinitely
as of last week data brewery had 1457
authorized investigators from 683 institutions
around the globe and was serving
up 96 000 hours of shared video
video data and documentation can improve
behavioral science because video captures
the richness of behavior and the subtle
details of the surrounding context video
is raw data about behavior but it's also a really
powerful form of documentation because it shows
procedures with more detail and more fidelity
than you can do with words or in still images
to capitalize on the richness of video you need
tools so we created the dataview tool dataview
is software that people can download
to their computers it's offered free
and openly to researchers here you see the power
of data view applied to a mother and baby at play
data view time locks user-defined codes to their
location in the video this spreadsheet is already
filled up with behavioral codes each column
is a different type of behavior for the baby
and for the mother the white cells are behaviors
that haven't happened yet the green cells are
behaviors that are happening right now you
know while you're seeing them on the video
and the red cells are behaviors that have just
happened you can see how quickly behaviors are
changing from one thing to another how
behaviors unfold in every domain at once
you can also use machine learning to annotate
video for example to track people's movements
and computer vision can track movements while
people do pretty complex tasks like this baby
cruising over gaps and a handrail
that it's holding on to for support
computer vision can also pick out objects
like people and plants and a bowl and a chair
computer vision done right can be really
beautiful um like it can track the location
and the orientation of each brick as this
child is building a construction with
duplo bricks and it can track the child's
hand position while they're doing it
and as you saw computer vision can even track
people's head and eye position to estimate
what they're seeing in three dimensions
the benefits of video recording
video annotation video sharing
video reuse i think the benefits are huge they'll
lead to increased transparency and reproducibility
and speed up scientific progress so
everyone go register on data breary
to sum it all up how does behavior develop well
infants acquire flexible functional behavior
from immense amounts of time distributed variable
very imperfect practice during everyday activity
starting everyday activity with a
changing body and changing skills
in a changing world in essence infants are
learning to learn that means they're learning
how to generate the requisite
perceptual information
from moment to moment that specifies which
behaviors they can do and how they should do them
and then finally as a science we have the
paradigms and the tools and the technology and
the infrastructure to really understand behavior
and its development we've just got to do it
this research is supported generously by
nih and nsf and various foundations and
data brewery is supported by nih and nsf and darpa
and foundations including the janice
mcdonald foundation so that's it thank you
do you have a preference for how to proceed with
the questions uh those of you in the chat uh can
you read them or do you want me to read them
to you um you can you can read them out or
people can just shout out their questions
sure uh well if anyone knows a little hand
yeah it has his yellow hand up all right
well thank you for a very fascinating talk
uh i'm a theoretical physicist so i know nothing
about your field i can imagine though that
spending an afternoon watching babies like that
must really be a real upper um so my question
though is that i remember about 10 years ago i
saw this incredible youtube video where they had
ducks that were running on a on a track and
somewhere along the track that put some ice and
and so it was interesting to see like how
these ducks would all of a sudden confront
this ice and like some ducks fell flat on their
asses and others ran like there was it was
that there was no ice at all and so this
was my original question that was in the
chat about this notion of universality it just
seems that some kids are really very uh you know
very adapt you know they're very um you know
proficient at a very young age and others are
really slow and so i wonder like how that
variability sort of factors into your study
um okay well i'm gonna you're seeing lots of
interesting things actually so um so first i'll
just talk about you know individual differences
there are of course individual differences in
everything about motor development when infants
acquire different skills and um and so on how
quickly the skills improve is less individual
differences than the age when it starts um and
uh but the the like the pathways themselves the
trajectories um so for something like perceiving
possibilities for action every baby i've studied
over the last 30 years shows that same trajectory
and so that's thousands of babies um you know
in like four different cities i don't know um
there's other things about motor development
where individual differences are very culturally
specific um and have to do with child-rearing
practices like if you know motor skills are
exercised or if they're constrained um so and
then there's individual differences in sort of
which skills babies show not just when but which
skills like in some cultures babies don't crawl
you don't have to it's not a rule or anything or
you can crawl after you walk or you know whatever
so there's lots of there's lots of differences
but i think the general idea that behavior
um is geared toward you know getting
things done in a functional way in a
real environment which means an environment
that's variable and filled with new things
that that is true for you know all the
animal kingdom and all the babies in it
um and they have to do it by learning to link
perception with action so thank you very much yeah
i don't know tyler you have a yellow hand up i do
that was anyone uh i think people might have been
ahead of me though i know i can't tell i i'm
i think melanie and tom were both ahead of me
uh melanie tom someone hi thank you for
this talk it was really interesting um
so i i was very much struck by the difference
between the the perception of the crawling and
the walking babies and i'm wondering you know the
idea that that you you learn this new skill and
you get this whole new perspective on the world
and that requires kind of relearning a bunch of
things i wonder if something similar happens in
language acquisition when kids learn sort of new
new things about grammar or new new concept
new linguistic concepts do they have to kind of
completely re-learn some conceptual ideas i
don't know if you have anything to say about that
i don't but i love that question and my closest
colleague is catherine thomas lamonda who
studies language and so
i'm going to pose it to her
there's lots of commonalities between motor
development and and language you know acquisition
but i don't know about you know like specificity
and transfer um yeah i don't know about that but
like this this surprising finding that you
know like what babies learn as crawlers doesn't
transfer it's also true that like what they learn
in sitting doesn't transfer to crawling or walking
even what they learn in cruising when they're
moving sideways holding on to things for support
doesn't seem to transfer to
walking um so you know i think
like when i you know i i first stumbled on
that a million years ago when i was doing
my dissertation and it seemed super like what
you just spent like months learning this stuff
but i think you know transfer always has to do
with what was learned in the first place and so
if babies were learning that big drop-offs
are risky or steep slopes are risky which is
totally true and they could have been learning
that then you should have seen transfer um
at this point like i think the only you know
reasonable explanation is that what infants are
learning is really like those squirrels in them
like you know like literally those guys in that
science paper they just like took their little
lab out into the park outside of berkeley and
and put some nuts or something in a thingy
and like these backyard squirrels just leave
you know do the stuff and the parkour strategies
they weren't supposed to do that they were just
supposed to gauge the distance they could leap but
they took advantage of things in the environment
and you know and we're doing all kinds of stuff
that like you know it was amazing and new and
novel um and unexpected from the point of view
of the researchers and i think that's really you
know the hallmark of behavior is and so in
that sense walking and talking are the same
you know they're both creative generous
skills you have to be able to do it on the fly
and you have to know from moment to moment
like you know what were you really asking
how am i really going to craft an
answer to it you know et cetera
great thank you yeah but i love
your question i'm going to ask kathy
melanie's question uh has totally turned
me around on how i was going to ask mine um
so my initial question had has to do with to what
extent um looking at uh babies learning to walk it
can be a model system for other kinds of
cognitive developments and cognitive skills and
that's essentially the question that melanie was
asking um so where i was gonna go with this was
the the new thing that you added um to the basic
story of space practice and um associated kinds
of things which is which was that very imperfect
practice is really important and babies have it
but as kids get older and as adults
develop like i i eventually became very
uh wary of of failing and quite sensitive
about not being able to do stuff right
so the loss of the the willingness to
to endure failure um is uh an important
thing and it might be an individual difference
that's important to further skill development
so that's that's one kind of thing but then what
melanie made me think of was these uh the the
early work on kind of two different kinds of kids
right kids who um start off with one word and then
put two words together and then put three words
together and so forth and then kids who uh usually
start talking a little bit later but start coming
out with multiple word combinations all at once
so i think melanie's pointing at the distinction
um between saying single words and getting syntax
and maybe that's a developmental milestone
that might be amenable to to your kind of
analysis karen so that's two different kinds
of kinds of takes on your talk it would which
was wonderful thank you well thanks you said
too much um and i lost track but you started
to what extent do i think walking is a
model system for everything um i think
it's a pretty good model system for um behavior
for motor behavior i also think it's a pretty
fine good damn fine you know model
system for development more generally
and i wrote a paper a couple of years ago
published in tix called development um uh
of walking but of walking is in parentheses and
then i think i had 15 suggestions and there's
lots and lots of things you know and we have you
know ticks have those little boxes call-out boxes
actually the call-out box is called walking and
talking um and so each of those 15 suggestions
about how development works is exactly true
in walking and also and talking oh um i don't
know who was next tyler jeff or mike i think
i was but forgive me if i'm wrong about that
uh great so no i love the talk fascinating i'm
also really taken by this i don't know uh ability
or inability to generalize from what they've
learned while they're crawling and i'm wondering
do you think there's a sort of a barrier to them
being able to generalize from what they've learned
they can crawl over or can't crawl over or do
you think there's it's almost like a strategic
decision to sort of balance uh sort of exploration
and exploitation and you think they're learning
more by taking more risks as walkers then they're
say you know they would have stayed in the game
by avoiding a few falls from you know maybe
generalizing their knowledge from crawling
i think i think they just can't um so in some
experiments we've actually done back-to-back
trials like put the baby standing you know
a new walker standing and then in their old
familiar crawling then standing then crawling
standing crawling and they're like you know
smart stupid smart stupid smart stupid um or we'll
do blocks of trials you know in some experienced
posture like sitting and then a novice posture
like crawling and even if like you know they've
just done the thing and they have alternative
strategies so like oh i'm in a crawler oh
too steep i'll back down it then you stand
them up and walk right over the edge i
think they just can't do any different i
think they just literally don't know and
um and i think what they don't know is like
what are the new body environment relations
um you know how does anyone learn any of that so
my hypothesis is well you know from what we've
seen of what everyday activity is like it must be
just you know immense amounts of time distributed
practice with different body environment relations
and then after a while you just are able to learn
like these are the critical parameters it's you
know ankle sway for walking or you know elbows and
wrists for crawling or whatever and you know these
are the allowable settings of those parameters and
you know this is how i get information in this
for this perception action system um and i had
this great big training study all designed and
then we had kovid and so if coveted will end
by the end of march i will know the answer but
otherwise i'm going to run out of money and i
will never know and that will be that i hope
that works out that's fascinating fascinating
um jeff or mike
i'm mute i'm new yes uh yeah thank you karen i uh
thoroughly enjoyed that talk and partially just
on a personal note because of covid um we had um
our grandson with us who were beginning at age
he probably was eight months to two living
with us without daughter and son-in-law
so it was fascinating watching this little baby
do the things that you've just talked about
and it's great being a grandparent because
you can be an observer and not thoroughly
engage because i noticed none of this when i
was a parent so it was fascinating watching
so but one of the things that um was touched
on this is actually a sort of repeat of
tommer melanie's question was the relationship to
cognitive development and the the the same kind of
process going on not so much language i was less
concerned about language was dealing with puzzles
and blocks and listening to uh being read to or
looking at little picture books and it just seems
um you know it's begging for sort of a
parallel study to go along with this because
the same kind of phenomena i love watching your
little pictures of the little girl and the little
boy falling over all the time and so on and just
picking themselves up but that was very true
of the cognitive development dealing with
putting you know little shape blocks inside
shapes and so on and the same thing and not
being bothered by it so there's all that
and then there's a leap question and that
is you know in the way you you discuss the
children the babies and we always
do we refer to them as they
but you know they're we are they i mean it's not
you know that's you and me i mean all of us are
that and one of the interesting questions it's
i don't know if it's psychological philosophical
is you know that's still me in a certain sense i
was a baby like that 80 years ago and now um and
am i doing the same things what is the residue of
all that and it goes to tom's remark about we've
become more and more risk-averse and so on and
of course physically there's good reasons because
as you say there's you know when you're small
and you fall it doesn't hurt if you're my age
you you break a thigh bone or whatever but
but but you become risk-averse intellectually
and i'm just wondering if you can
see any connection between that
now i have one last thing which you also alluded
to because you started to talk with it and that is
the comparative kind of studies that is are there
analogous studies that have actually been done
doing pretty much what you've done with animals
of different sizes and interesting question about
the timing of all this uh especially because
we're we may even be unique but we're certainly
um unlike our all the other mammals we're useless
for the first few years of our lives especially
that first watching my grandson it was frightening
to see how vulnerable that baby was relative to a
little mouse or a cat or a dog or a horse and i'm
wondering how that affects comparative learning
you know in terms of timing of events and so on
so that's a sort of slightly vague question anyway
i'm sorry there's a whole bunch of things that
came to my mind as you talk which i thoroughly
enjoyed i i love that you guys have some how that
is that that sparked all these things um so i
wrote down some of it and i'll hope that i can get
to it um so the relation to cognitive development
um i think there's two ways to look at it one
way is to look at you know walking or motor
development as a model system for development and
you know in other domains and and and they're you
know i think uh you know many of the things
hold true especially something like errors so
you know think about in language development
you know babies mispronounce everything they
have grammatical errors they have every kind
of error but it doesn't stop them from wanting
to communicate and it doesn't really even get in
the way of communicating it's like a baby getting
up in 1.8 seconds after a fall well you know
whatever they just someone figures that out and
the communication keeps moving forward and they
have to do that you know so they have to practice
to acquire these skills that require so much
generativity and flexibility and so set up
the system so that you don't penalize them for
errors in the early stages and then both of you
guys alluded to you know the sort of other end of
the spectrum and i'm getting close to there so i
think about this one too um on data break there's
um an amazing data set of false and elderly people
um it's steve rabenovich's data set
and he put cameras up in nursing homes
um in eldercare homes like in the public areas
and and then just captured false like that
and and the falls you have to see them
for yourself i can't i i don't want to
figure out how to screen share all that with you
they're amazing like you can almost hear it like
you know like the babies are like you know like
they're like little pieces of seaweed and you
know these beautiful like super wrestler
falls and then the elderly people you know
crank and elderly people fall a lot i mean
that's that's part of this you know one of
the bad things about being old but a
lot is like one to six times a year
a lot for a baby is you know 39
times per hour in motion you know
it's like it's daily it's you know it's hourly
it's all the time right so a lot is relative
and for the elderly people the videos are horrific
like they don't get up in three seconds someone
has to come and cart them away and then you know
it's horrible so um so it's really different and
i don't know you know how much similarity there
is to re-learning um than there is to learning
in the first place i think you know the sort
of the system has been very well designed for
learning these kinds of things in the first place
but maybe not so well designed for relearning or
for learning later in life and language is another
great example if you're you know young and being
exposed to multiple languages people learn
them and it's seamless and flawless and fine
but if you're you know an adult it's really
hard for most people to learn a new language
um and even if they put in the same number of
years it could be 30 years later and they're still
mispronouncing and having grammatical errors
um so there's this model system idea of the
relation between you know motor behavior and
the hidden things like cognition and whatever um
but i have two other things to say about it first
of all okay cognition is great and important you
know fine hats off but it's freaking hidden you
don't know none of us know you don't know in a
squirrel you don't own a baby you don't even know
in me i don't you don't know that what i'm saying
is what i truly believe all you know is what i'm
saying all you've got is the behavior maybe you
can know if my brain is active here or there or
whatever if you you know put me in a eg cap or
locked me in a magnet that's all you know you know
so it's not like behavior is our only window in
and then a third thing is that behavior cascades
into cognition and emotion and social interaction
and perception and everything else and into
language so what's a great example a great example
is that uh when babies are doing something
their caregivers at least in the us like
western caregivers tend to comment on what the
baby's doing so if the baby's you know holding
a pen they'll say the word pen or they'll say oh
are you trying to write with that or whatever so
they'll name the actions and the objects that
the babies are doing so in this like so-called
buzzing blooming confusion it's not so buzzy and
blooming because half the time they can't even see
all the buzz in the bloom because you know the
world hasn't expanded to that yet our world our
supposed world of the baby is buzzing and blooming
not the baby's world and then it's structured like
the curriculum for learning is highly structured
so you know the caregiver says exactly the words
at exactly the right time it's not like you know
the philosopher's quan oh i wonder how they ever
could ever have done it you know we must have
to build it all in because no you don't have to
build any constraints the natural world is highly
structured and it works out really well that way
so caregivers are more likely to say words when
babies are doing things when they say the words
while the baby is actually looking at the thing
or in the midst of doing the action then the
babies are far more likely to add those words
to their vocabulary to know what the words mean
so um you know movements behavior cascade into
all the rest and you know many developmental
psychologists starting with piaget you know
have supposed that these kinds of sensory motor
experiences are critical for you know forming
the foundation for cognition so that's what i
got to say on that one oh comparative studies
yeah there are tons of comparative studies um
and all kinds of really cool interesting animals
like snakes you know doing the squirrel task you
know how does the snake decide if it can leap
its slithery body from one branch to another
monkeys of course you know etc and maybe the
most fun thing is robots now so people trying
to build embodied systems the really good
people are trying to make you know autonomous
systems that are doing their own thing like
peter stone you know so he also we we're doing
stuff in simulation but he also has embodied
robots you know like actual ones and it's not
like there's a little graduate student with
a joystick playing soccer for the robot the
robots are playing soccer by themselves and
that's the goal right so the only thing robots
are not able to do is have bodies and skills
that develop only animals can do that so far
maybe that was a bit too
impassioned there at the end sorry
it wasn't hey okay i have a small question and
a big maybe a bigger question though i don't
know which of them is the big and which is the
smaller so the first is a bit is related to what
jeffrey asked i mean what you're saying right
is that uh in certain situations babies will
do something and not care about the risk which
seems a very risky behavior so i imagine that
like the squirrels when they're small won't
just step off the tree and fall off eh yeah
but not all of them so the quest so there must be
something that modulates like how much risk you
take versus what your environment like of course
our environment is also very dangerous right
i mean if a baby would just walk off to the
street it would be run over so parents make
very short to kind of adjust the environment so
that because they know how bad their babies are
but there must be i mean if we go to other
animals there must be some modulation between
how dangerous your environment is and what kind of
risks you take um so yeah so that was more common
hey the second question is um you said that
babies change all the time right they wear
jacket they grow two inches they but it seems
like only in this a very radical change from
a crawling to standing they forget everything is
this really true so this is there's just one step
where they follow everything and then all the
others they can transfer yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's the easy questions because i have a [ __
] ton of data about it so if you take a baby and
change its body dimensions with you know loads
um on their shoulders or whatever or put slippy
shoes on their feet or sticky shoes on their
feet or make one leg you know a different size
or whatever um they can recalibrate on the fly
literally from trial to trial um so it's not
i think it's actually like think of it your
own like you're almost coming at it backward
so in everyday life they pick up a toy it changes
the location of their center of mouth you know
they their mom takes their shoes off now they're
running around in slippy socks and now they're
barefoot and now they're on the hardwood floor
now they're on the carpet and all these different
experiences are different body environment
relations and so the thing that that generalizes
this is my hypothesis across all that what they're
taking away from all that varied experience
is oh this is how i know what my body can do
right now in this thing you know in this dress
in these high heels you know i got dressed up
i don't know why you know whatever like i can
tell like i stand up and now i can tell like in
these shoes i can i couldn't i would do something
different than i would do in my sneakers and i
don't have to know that explicitly i can feel it
i can tell it and babies get to that point with
enough practice with that perception action system
so that one is easy um yeah it's only these
radical changes from one sort of one whole
developmental system to another um and then
the thing about modulating risk and whatnot
i've been thinking a lot about it too maybe
not in the same way that you are it sounds like
you're you know exploration
exploitation reinforcement learning etc
um i i have a bunch of you know machine learning
computer science computer vision colleagues on
on a darpa grant and we talk and think about
these things all the time but let me tell you so
so i talked about you know the environment
expanding as babies get new skills right and
i sort of presented it as this good thing like
whoa the world is getting bigger and that's
but as the world grows it gets riskier and
riskier as well and so um actually last week
i just had put together a new talk on that
let me think we did falling so falling is
falling is like the second or third leading cause
of accidental injury and death and and children
under two so it does happen um but when do they
get hurt you have to fall from a height will they
fall from a height yeah you know like like the
stuff you saw from my lab that's very robust
yeah if you leave the window open and let your
crawling walking baby near the window they
might fall out the window and they do and it's
horrible or the flood on the stairs or whatever so
don't leave the window open and have barriers
and you know whatever um but each skill like oh
now my baby has a pincher grip well now that means
they can pick up things small enough to choke on
oh marvelous my baby has manual actions well now
they can open poison containers and die from that
oh now maybe whatever they can drown they can
suffocate and all these horrible things can happen
to babies but it's also true in every stage of
development you know so like an eight-year-old
who can really understand what this whole covid
thing is about that is a different kind of
risk because of their cognitive development
and when your children become teenagers and
you know can like go out in the world and
have dates and friends and partners and do
you know like the as the as their as our world
expands there's opportunities for learning yay
there's also risks scary um and for babies under
two or really kids under five there's nothing
safety guidelines are not even based on
science the government there's nothing
and in our country there's not even there's
there's there's huge problems with environmental
justice the only thing you can do is be
a vigilant caregiver that's it you know
and so since like babies like all those things
are our leading causes accidentally trained uh um
and that's in you know modern society where we're
doing our best i guess cave babies and neanderthal
babies and whatever fell off cliffs and choked
on rocks and did all these you know also
i have this new grant with the epa um and um you
know you're talking about like your grandchildren
and like i don't even notice all this stuff
there's so many interesting behaviors that
babies do that we don't even notice so one of
those behaviors is putting stuff in their mouths
babies are mouthing things like 40 something times
an hour their hand or objects or whatever most of
which have been on the floor in the like the last
10 seconds so three second rule it's touched the
floor that means that they're adjusting dust
you know whatever whatever came in contact
you know with the floor and um and there's
lots of bad things in dust right and so
yeah i guess the bottom line is you know the
world grows at every point in development the
world grows until we get old and nasty and then
it starts to shrink again but as the world is
growing new good things new opportunities also
new potential risks for children all you can
do is be vigilant and try not to helicopter
so much that they can't learn anything
um katrine helena anyone yes sorry so
i was wondering how important really
the the effect of not punishing errors
is and whether we can learn something
from that for adult learning because for children
it's all it's that when they fall they don't hurt
when they learn a language any mistake they do
it's just it's cute if they start talking but
when i learn a new language if we start learning
new physical things it looks embarrassing in the
beginning yeah and and if we i don't know if we
could just learn um not to punish our errors when
learning new things whether just the fact that
adults learn slower than babies or then children
has partly to do with errors being more negatively
responded to among adults yeah absolutely i love
that i love that whole suggestion um so for
something like falling there's really not a
lot we can do about it we're too big and we
move too fast and if we fall you know we're
gonna get hurt much more than a baby would would
do but for something like language you know they
have like those immersion language camps and the
idea is exactly that like you you're forced to
use the language you're gonna make mistakes
everyone's doing it just get over yourself
or learning to dance you know so immersion
interventions you know that's that's one approach
but it only works in the domains where it works
you know in some domains mistakes are costly so
helena i just have a quick curiosity question
because we've already taken a bit more of your
time than we were supposed to uh but you're giving
us so much to think about it's awesome um i'm
actually curious about if you have any data on the
variation of movements that babies produce over
the developmental course so do you have a period
where they tend to have more variation because i
recall like data but for my master's degree so
it might be outdated uh that there's a time in
the developmental course where they tend to have
uh bigger steps and then they kind of regress to
smaller ones a bit but i might also misrecall it
so i was just wondering do you have any pattern on
like amplitude and speed of movements over
the developmental course you're studying um
okay i love that question and and my lab
has i feel like we're trying you know
we're trying to attack it ourselves
it depends what you're measuring so
if you measure like sort of in a standard way like
you know so straight path or treadmill walking
then variability is going to decrease and it's
always highest in the acquisition of the skill um
same thing for like you know controlled
reaching or something like that any skill
that anyone has ever studied um if you do it
in the kind of standard traditional way then
variability is highest in the beginning um
if you do sort of more complex skills like
um there's a um like maybe swinging on a
swing or um there's like these ski trainers
that people have used where you have to go
like um variability is really high while the
person is just figuring out this task then
it gets low so they're sort of clamping down
and then it starts to loosen up again because
now they're exploiting passive forces and
they're kind of like getting the swing of it and
so things become sort of more variable again so
all of this sort of and then and then if you
look at natural action like natural walking
it's it's variable like high high
high high as much as we put so high
you know whatever the outcome measure high um
so i and i don't know anymore what it means
when we do the really tightly controlled tasks
i still do them because i'm scared no one will
publish the paper if i don't tag on like the
standard task so i do and you know it's easy
enough to do it but i don't know what it means i
really don't know what it means and largely for
like sort of developmental trajectories natural
actions show the same pathways so i don't know
yeah but oh my goodness we love that question
and and it's and there's and it's so hard and
there's so many ways to measure variability and
you know i'm not especially good at it either and
so there's all of that on top of it but if
you know stuff offline tell me um nothing we
can give you data or whatever okay we should talk
offline i know more in adult modern learning than
developmental but it's a different conversation
tell me if you have a short-ish question if
possible because we're already 20 minutes past
when we're supposed to end i was just uh going
to once again go back to the risk aversion kind
of thing that came up from multiple people uh most
lately katrine and you know i i think it might
be useful here to distinguish between um physical
threats and threats to the to the self-concept um
you know like for example a stereotype threat as
an analogy to the kinds of difficulties um that
karen's been talking about and people are more
more or less robust later in life to threats
to their self-concept and some people are just
willing to go out there and try anything new and
it doesn't matter if they fail and so forth but i
i there's a lot known about individual differences
in response to stereotype threat and so forth and
maybe that's uh an analog for to to some of these
uh early motor development kinds of things if
if everybody could be as robust to thrust to
self-concept as babies are to to threats to their
physical self then a um learning in lots
of domains might go better but b we might
need more protection uh we might need caregivers
around us all the time to keep our self concepts
in intact rather than falling out the window so
forth that was what i finally came to think about
yeah thanks
um i think that might be a good note to end on
if you don't want to add more to it um thanks
again for uh well the beautiful talk and all the
energy in answering all of our very long questions
um and hopefully we're gonna get to see you at
sfi at some point in person um i hope so yeah it
was it was thank you guys and thanks for sticking
out this long and um and susan for inviting me and
you guys for letting me do it it's super fun thank
you i think we could all say it was our pleasure